opening day 2.0
the flyover always awesome at coors
field fans 100 capacity starting today
it's the rockies and the pirates coming
up next
today is denver native kyle freeland and
also for kyle he's coming off his best
performance by far
and he gets a strikeout
diaz held on
sarah gonzalez is gone one out in the
top of the first
two two
oh no it's called strike three
that was a change up that was a change
up well received by diaz behind the play
one ball one strike here's the pitch to
reynolds
line drive to right center field and
that is going to get down
and reynolds has himself uh another hit
and extending
his hitting streak he is on quite a tear
one or two on moran
and his hands have been a target lately
we're just hoping that uh you know it
hurts
you're just hoping that it's not broken
and so at least uh for now
moran will stay in
it's just the first inning but this is
the 25th pitch
and he's gonna end up striking outside
two are left to hit and a hit batter oh
there's concern with colin miranda you
see him there i think he's done yeah as
he was throwing around to the infielders
he had the the finger across the neck
type of thing saying he's done and so
philip evans will enter the game tyler
anderson getting ready to throw 482 eura
and this ball is latched to left
trevor continues to swing the bat well
two out single for story
out to center
reynolds has the final out and the 11
pitch first inning for tyler anderson
strike three that's four strikeouts
for freeland
gotta hit that pitch it's a strike if
you take it so
he does and he's got a two out single
oh one on
anderson and this is on the ground kyle
doe for it he's fine and flip to second
will end the inning
[Applause]
weak fly ball out to reynolds
crone is gone
3-2 pitch
line drive to right and there is polanco
to make the catch one two three go the
rockies after two and here's rymel tapia
evans over at first short lead by
freeland he's going back to the bag as
the pitch is delivered another tapper to
anderson throws low to second going down
to make the play is gonzales freeland
out no relay throw so
tapia reaches on the fielder's choice i
mean short of being a base hit i don't
mind the trade-off though with top
running right now get kyle back into the
dugout
this ball is live to right a bait's hit
for dazza and this will be going to the
royal it will pass morocco and tapio
around third he's going to score dowser
heading the
[Applause]
it turns into a triple for dazza
[Applause]
bronco's starting to go over and then
realize oh no this ball is going to get
by me he never created an angle back
to cut that ball off from going to the
wall that allowed tapia to score from
first and dawson for his second trip of
this year
four five and six against kyle freeland
who
has given up three hits
pirates have left three but far yet to
score against freeland this is on the
ground max spins got it and he throws
one gun oh mack doing his thing over at
third that's not an easy ball it might
look like one but the the english that
that ball had on it
one two
swung on it missed and that strike out
number six second time stallings has
been banned by freely
freeland the lefty
with another 2-2 pitch and a swing and a
missing a pitch in the dirt it's in the
dirt and now elias diaz has trouble
picking it up and he throws to first and
the ball is dropped by the first baseman
crone
it's a strikeout and
newman reaches
runners at first and second with no one
out all this unfolds the bunch down to
freeland he'll go to third and they get
the out there kyle didn't make a great
throw
ryan mcmahon stayed with it but it
prevented any chance of maybe getting
anderson at first base
as eric gonzalez bounces at the third
mcmahon will tag the runner throw to
first or did he tag the runner he did
not tag the runner
gonzalez is
out at first
and
i'm just wondering from the rockies
perspective the crew chief greg gibson
saying
he was
not tagged but it ends up being a put
out
third to first 5-3 hayes is struck out
twice so far today and he'll bounce it
off freeland's glove he recovers throws
to first and got him
elias diaz
hit the ball sharply to the shortstop
gonzalez's first time up
centerfield deep reynolds to the truck
to the right
that's a big fly
and that's a two-nothing colorado
rockies lead
third home run for diaz and that shows
you the power that he has taking it out
to dead central
center cut diaz did not miss this one
got everything behind it
that is now drew get this the 14th home
run tyler anderson's given up to a
right-handed battery
and kyle bunts again it's going to be a
tough chance anderson
can't field it clearly
and he knows his buddy freeland runs
well
so his actions get sped up
drives this one to the left
gamma will cut it off
freeland to third daza into second
with a double and
kyle freeland lagging his way to third
and
that's his hand he was stretching it out
a little bit at first so i was watching
him on that run
everything's good for kyle until he
started around second base about halfway
there that hammy starts to tighten up on
him yeah kyle's taking a few steps
trying to flex that
or flexing that leg and i think he's
gonna leave
yeah with a pitcher you're just not
going to
take the risk the unfortunate thing for
the rockies is that they're going to
have to
turn to the bullpen
at least an inning earlier if not two
with the way freeland has been pitching
now it'll be up to tyler kinley to hold
this two-nothing lead and hopefully it's
a reversal of fortunes for the rockies
bullpen because in milwaukee and on this
road trip it hadn't been pretty
strike three called painted the outside
edge with a backdoor slider out number
one for kindly
ground ball headed up the middle and a
base hit the second baseman
rogers gets a glove on it just to slow
it down but it's into center field for a
base hit
pitch slow grounder toward short story
will go to second they get the force on
stallings the catcher and a good sixth
inning for tyler kinley this is a
pirates team that
while offensively
has had its issues through most of the
year has been swinging the bat pretty
well as of late
over the last nine games in which
they've won six this pitch is swung on
and driven to center field daza moving
back towards right center still going
and he makes the catch as he bumps into
the wall
jonathan dazza defensively
hauls in another one
marvelous catch by the rockies center
fielder so it'll be jacob stallings
right on right with daniel bard bard's
first pitch to stallings is lined
towards center field it's gonna drop for
a base hit the pirates
trying to put the pressure on a rocky's
closer who's
been in a slump here's the a1
slider in the air to right charlie's got
room coming up tucks
2.0